hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and i am not
as beefy as other characters in this
series but you know what i can pack a
punch
of deeply thought out opinions on hunter
hunter while tapping my
subscribe button see i can be just
like both biski and hiskey who are let's
be honest
are heroes and role models of this okay
no i can't even suggest that don't be
like them that's an awful idea don't you
get mad at me
you two are absurdly dangerous people
let's ignore their looks of disapproval
and talk about them instead as we get
into episodes 72
and 73 episode 72 and we're closing in
on
crunchyroll time the back and forth
cutting between sargeras and gone trying
to learn a technique was great up to a
point
the jumps told us that something
important is happening or about to
happen but it didn't tell us how long it
would take
which meant that as the episode
continued i felt increasingly tense
about the entire situation
that said the increased nothingness that
was happening
kiwa and biski's relaxed sort of air to
it all and
gone's inability to progress at all sort
of broke that
tension like that testy pop that i just
had it it all just broke
the issue was that we went from sargeras
who i feel takes himself far too
seriously
i i think it's the eyebrows probably to
gone failing
bisky standing by and kilwa sitting
around while i understand that
kilwa can't actually do anything because
his hands are recovering
and i understand that biski does
actually need to stand by and i
understand
that there's little she can do to speed
things along now that that's been
explained
instead of the characters actually
taking up new positions or even just
frowning a little or really doing
anything that shows the importance of
what they're doing they took up what i'm
going to call their
base cell positions by which i mean if
they were drawn
on average this is probably what they'd
look like you know sargeras always looks
intense and broody
kilwa is always chilling in a relaxed
casual position and biski is always
standing by
the fact that we spent what felt like
half the episode in that repeated
holding pattern grew visually boring
and that's somewhat frustrating because
the circumstances are
actually incredible we have a group of
psychopaths chasing after people with a
moral code
those people with a moral code are doing
everything they can to give many
psychopaths time to develop skills and
plans to stop the bigger psychopaths
we have a crying businessman we have
gone not yet able to do a thing he will
be able to do when he suddenly and
probably in the next episode finds
exactly the right metaphor to
characterize what the thing is
we have broody moral man about to die
probably because he has no help from the
crying boss that just canceled the
entire project and we have set
up for the next arc just crouched on the
ground with keelois brother
apparently kaluto joining the phantom
troupe while hiskey lovingly strokes
his telescope watch out kaluto what is
it with kilwa's family that they just
show up in places for a moment and
you know probably disappear again there
is insom
so so very much happening in this
episode but it felt
underplayed and i am grumpy about it i
love that we're being reminded
periodically that they're there
their care for crawler is still
astounding because it's something that
feels more wholesome than i'd really
like to see it as
and i dream of the day kromo gets his
powers back then berates them soundly
for actually bothering to go through all
that rather than living to his ideals
and
just continuing the truth they're a
close-knit bunch and pink hair puppet
lady really just helped his soccer's
telescope reach its full length by
telling him
she would hunt him down if he killed her
boss beyond the adorable nature of the
troop it's also a good reminder that
hiskey said to call him if they need and
that for all his complications in the
way he acts this is quite a
straightforward person with
straightforward motives
for all his weirdness he refuses to let
gon die until he's got what he wanted
out of him which is a full potential
battle
worthy of a schwing does hiski plan on
sword fighting gone
okay let's not answer that despite the
obvious and immediate image it brought
to mind and you know what i'm not at all
sorry to distract you from all that
let's talk about biski's preoccupation
with being rubbed
how does that power work how can a
special technique be that of
massage i guess she's the closest this
world has come so far to a healer
she has the power of relaxation on her
side and you know what in a world where
everyone's trying to kill everyone else
or find things
maybe a good hunter can find out
information if they use a good massage
technique maybe it turns out the massage
therapist she conjures can break spines
or
does acupuncture 2 and paralyze it no it
really doesn't look as though that's
what the power does
it truly looks like a power is what i
would probably realistically have as a
power that's a point
in the comments which i'll actually read
this time let me know what kind of power
you would have and what it would be
based on i feel like that seems fun
and i'm sure everyone's thought about
this so like let's have that
conversation as we step into the real
world
going back to the episode as we step
into the real world it's a whole new
game for bomber but it also has a whole
new set of implications for gone this is
the first time maybe probably i think
that gone has been in a situation where
the outcome almost has to be lethal the
bombers aren't going to let their cards
go without a fight the abilities they
have mean they can't be disarmed and
until the game is done
gone can't just tie them up and get what
he's aiming to get they're
indiscriminately killing everyone now
and if gone isn't powerful enough to
kill them
or overwhelm them in some way i'm not
sure how they'll move forward and finish
the game
it also feels as though it's the end of
the road for sargeras and i have a
sneaking suspicion bomber may have
touched mr batera or someone they care
about either that or crollow's there and
has said something or karapika's boss
has been in contact with them through
neon i i get a
sort of suspicion that whatever's wrong
with mr batera is linked to one of our
other threads so
let's get into episode 73 and find out
what note
i was wrong opening with sargeras not
returning is
actually fantastic their time is up and
it gives us so much to think about
during the intro the arc is getting
close to the end and we get all the
information we need about how tense
things are from how focused the other
two are on that information
but gone is studying something else now
is interesting all their eggs are
supposedly in the gone basket
even once they'd spoken to guareno greg
korinu
even once they'd spoken to you know
spiky hair guy even once they'd spoken
to guerino there was a belief that
everything was ongoing
looking back from the end of this
episode i was definitely wrong in that i
was also wrong in thinking batera's
tears were related to anything other
than the actual game
his story was heartbreaking but because
i wasn't particularly attached to the
game as a concept
nor did i really get time to think about
what each individual card did or how it
worked
despite knowing the game finishers got
to take cards into the real world i
didn't have any big emotions related to
finding out that he was specifically
after breath of archangel nor did i have
any particular connection to him
it totally makes sense and it's nice to
have a motive for him but i
don't care which is odd i cared more
about the npcs in the game than i do
about
probably because it just didn't seem
important at any point
up to now it's good that takashi decided
to tie up that loose end we needed for
that to happen but i also would have
actually preferred to see what seguero's
response was
knowing that he no longer needs to
finish the game yet also knowing that
there are people in there that he's made
a deal with
he seems the sort to be moralistic
enough to at least consider the
implications of not needing to return to
the game
even getting a message back into it
somehow if we don't see sargeras again i
feel like that's a bit of a loss of
character development i would actually
have liked to see
the fakes and the card switcheroo was a
great tie-in and a great way to make
sure the tension stayed on the
importance of this plan
and the battle but still speaking of the
plan we jumped around in people's minds
this episodes we got to see
i think everyone's perspective on how
they thought the situation was going and
i
loved it there is a great focus when we
jump around through perspectives that we
really didn't get when the characters
were physically jumping around last
episode and i appreciate this
especially since the plan to separate
meant that i first got mad at gone for
going off plan
because every time gone is given a plan
he wanders away from but then to see
biscuity and keel are doing what they do
best
um biscuit we need to talk i remember
saying a while back that biscuit looked
too young for her stated age and that if
she'd been as young as all that there
would have been different reactions but
to know she's actually super strong and
really big and that it's all a choice is
astounding the level of men she must be
using to maintain that change when she's
around
everyone all the time is incredible and
that it's all due to personal preference
is just so totally bisky i love it
what it doesn't do is give us a full
understanding of the extent of biski's
powers and i
am suddenly refocused on her as a
character i want to know
why didn't her hair grow with her why
didn't her clothes shred
ah speaking of clothes actually when did
kilwa get his usual outfit back
i know it's a small detail and i'm sure
it's inconsequential and there have been
a lot more important things happening
but i suddenly realized he has his full
outfit back and i demand to know when
this happened jumping to kill was fight
because biscuits ended very quickly and
easily after her reveal
it was great overall to see him planning
and trapping sequentially his mind is
his greatest power and while i believe
gone is closer to hisoka in terms of
combat
philosophy kilwa is probably closest to
hisoka in execution kilwa's enjoyment of
tricking and trapping and testing things
on his opponents is something i could
well imagine hisoka doing and the fact
that neither biski nor kilwa
actually wanted to show these abilities
to the others in their group the fact
that only god
has shown his powers to the others says
a lot about how they interact with the
world compared to the way that he does
he can hide his abilities as we know he
hasn't shown bomber everything he can do
and we're waiting for exactly the right
moment to get to that but he's a lot
more of an open book while not
actually being an open book at all and
yes that's a contradiction but hear me
out going into god's head
in this episode is the first significant
time we've done so since the hunter exam
i think we don't see the world from
god's perspective very often at all we
see it from biscuits hiskies
almost every enemy and everyone trying
to understand the kid but we really
don't see things from his perspective
and that means a lot of what we think
about gone is unverifiable i can't pin
down his motives for sure
because all we have is what he says
verbally or
how he acts not how he thinks or what he
thinks
so everything is a guess or externally
driven narrative of the character which
is a fantastic way to avoid pinning down
your mane
or dropping new information on us
ultimately we underestimate gone as much
as his opponents do which is why i'm
always confused by
what exactly makes his head steam or
what decisions he's making because on
the surface he's a simpleton maybe
but when you get a little deeper he
knows what he's doing or at least he
knows what he should be doing and how it
should be done
but he actively chooses not to do things
that way and because we have so little
time
inside his head we don't know why he's
not doing things that way
other than what he's verbally saying to
others which might not be the true
or accurate on a very deep
level and on that we know that now the
real battle begins
we skipped through each of the scenes of
underestimation to get to this point the
point before biski and kilauea can get
back to gone
what will he do and how will he react
and on that
the end frame of this episode is
beautifully composed
with the bright red of the hand while
the physically imposing larger bomber
with ice hidden behind glasses and
sharp lines dives towards god whose
musculature is now showing very clearly
everything about the image tells us that
whatever trap they've set
is work and gun's hopefully going to
make a fantastic comeback as bisky said
he can survive more than one explosion
he's not like the others
bomber has yet to realize that he also
has yet to realize that gone is the most
stubborn character
i have ever seen in an anime not just in
determination but in sheer
stubbornness he wants to find his dad to
do that he has to win the game or finish
it he's gonna do that
i'd have no doubt that he's gonna do
that the next episode is going to be a
juicy battle i hope and because i want
to get there i'm gonna sign off here
because that's it from me if you enjoyed
this discussion and want to see more you
can click here here and here
there's also a discord and a range of
other things here and here have a great
day and i'll see you next time